all right let's talk about your body and
what's wrong with it uh uh no seriously
uh i know that you're a rash we're
friendly uh and we are very friendly i
know that you uh you work out a lot you
take a lot of pride in being in good
shape clearly clearly look conan i can
help you whenever you want i don't want
your help like you i was born jacked
i was a jacked fetus i was
i was jacked in utero and i remained
jacked
i'm just gonna keep saying jack do you
notice they keep laughing every time you
say you're jacked
i know i'm cause that's their way of
agreeing with me it's uh oh i saw there
was a paparazzi photo that i saw of you
recently and this was taken very
recently and it looked like you were
flexing for the paparazzi you're going
out of your way yeah to show off those
guns is that something you do when you
see cameras how dare you that's normal
no uh i weren't wearing the sunglasses
because i was flexing for 10 minutes to
wait i was waiting for someone to take a
photo and
uh and then i then after that they
didn't print those but i i got undressed
and did a lot of push-ups and some
squats
this was right in front of grand central
station so it was you're doing what you
can again i was arrested yeah what is it
let me ask you about this in the
exercise world what is it with the
obsession with the butt now
it seems like it's a constant everyone
wants their butt to look amazing yeah i
are you gonna ever join that bandwagon i
can't i i have an andy you'll back me up
on this i have no ass whatsoever i was
just i have i'm one of those guys
there's just nothing there there's a
straight drop it's just yes it's just
all back it actually goes it goes in and
then just it actually goes in you can
put a book there you know that's yeah
and take it out and read it and then
it's time to go to sleep and you shove
it into the area where it should have a
butt and you go to sleep that is when
he's in the rain he'll find birds in
there
no it's true i don't have i'm that's
never going to happen for me but i know
that a lot of i know women want their
butts yeah but they're a lot of insights
now yeah there's like butt i feel like
it's all squat i feel like when they dig
us up in 2000 years they will go what
happened in 2018 was gravity pulling
harder on people did they need to have
huge muscular butts and legs all the
time right uh because i feel like
jennifer lopez kind of broke open the
butt craze and because you used to all
just be huge boobs tiny skinny people
and now it's it's butt central and it's
i love it you love it
yeah you do a lot of stuff what's good
for your
what are the
what are the exercises that you do i do
this one where i
this isn't an exercise this is oh you
don't want to know what i'm doing right
i don't
it's i'm
i'm whatever it is i'm telling hr
i like to think about a small bear cub
right there and we're releasing them
into the wild uh no i do a lot i do a
lot of i do a lot of squats because you
got to work on the core i cannot believe
we're talking about this but uh well
i've taken over dr phil's show so uh
yeah this is this is momentarily dr phil
oh well talks about health or is it dr
oz no i don't know neither of them are
real doctors no
no dr phil's in great physical shape so
yeah his mustache works out every day